[Music]
it's that time again for willow smith
on friday the 20 year old shaved her
head for the third time in her life
during an epic ending to her facebook
live event promoting her fourth studio
album
lately i feel everything i'm always
shaving my head at monumental times in
my life when things are
really changing and this is definitely
one of those moments
it was fitting that during her big chop
the singer was rocking out to a pop punk
version of her 2010 debut hit song
with my hair
[Music]
but with my hair tour in 2012 marked the
first time the then
11 year old willow shaved her head after
expressing
she was ready to end the tour she went
to her room that night i went to my room
she comes down that morning she shaved
her head balls
in the middle of her with my hair tour
will smith
says his daughter's act of rebellion
taught him a very valuable lesson
why do it if you're not going to have
fun and he got it and took her home
i want to be promoting positivity i want
to be promoting
expression and i feel like with my hair
was just
a huge encouragement
to people to just be themselves
and to help others do the same willow
has always found a way to combine her
hair
and art choices to send a powerful
message
last march she shaved her head while she
spent 24 hours in a glass room
as part of a performance art
installation demonstrating the eight
emotional stages related to anxiety
there's a certain freedom that comes
with that most recently
she convinced her mom jada pinkett smith
to also make a bold choice
by shaving her head last week the
actress took to instagram to show off
her new look
writing in the caption quote willow made
me do it because it was time to let go
but my 50s are about to be divinely lit
with this shed
recently willow opened up to e.t about
what she's learned from working side by
side with her mother and
grandmother during their time on the red
table talk thus far
i think that just
even not in the immediate
like show circumstances but in hearing
their stories
and then hearing what they've been
through together in their past
um seeing how
intense the evolution has been from
where you guys
started at and how your relationship
started
yeah um and how much your relationship
has grown
because you individually have grown yeah
and i don't know it's just inspiring to
see every time because
i feel like as humans it's just so easy
to feel
hopeless and so easy to feel
like you can't change or like things
won't change
and they can and they can they really
really really care